here's a voicemail I got with a very
common question about pseudoscience I'm
gonna play it for you and then we will
talk about it this is in the context of
the pseudoscience miniseries that has
recently wrapped up I guess I'd say hey
David I just had a quick comment on the
pseudoscience miniseries you guys did
and you've studied the issue really
really in-depth but my question is even
if it is complete and utter
pseudoscience doesn't think there is a
value to talking to someone about some
of the problems you have so when you go
to a psychic and they do a cold read on
you
they get you to talk about some stuff
you're really wanting to talk about
normally yeah and this can be very
therapeutic for though for people
actually doing the psychic so there
should be value in therapy yeah it's not
therapy though it's not therapy that's
the point this is a common refrain
listen even if it's not actually real
even if homeopathy isn't actually real
as such going and speaking to a
homeopathy can be a good experience or a
psychic same thing we have real stuff
called
psychotherapy and counseling and Social
Work and psychologists pseudoscience
isn't victimless people get scammed out
of money people often forego actual
treatment a psychic might get you to
talk about something that relates to
your depression and that might have some
positive effect but they're not
qualified to determine if you are for
example a suicide risk they simply
aren't so that is not a good argument
for me just because we identify that the
benefit of some of these quote therapies
which they aren't actually is merely
having a conversation with someone
that's not a defense that is a valid one
to me okay so common refrain totally
bogus great bonus show coming up I'm out
of time but it's a good one sign up WW
join pakman.com patreon.com slash david
pakman show